[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio more
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español
américa latina es hoy en día el
epicentro de la crisis de la pandemia
del pronaa virus que afecta al mundo
desde el 2019 con más de 600 millones de
habitantes que representan
aproximadamente el 9 por ciento de la
población mundial américa latina
registra hoy el 40 por ciento de las
muertes que se están produciendo por
esta pandemia en todo el mundo para
hablar de ello saludamos aquí en el
estudio a christoph ventura director de
investigaciones del instituto de
relaciones internacionales y
estratégicas el iris que acaba de
presentar un informe que se llama kobe
19 en américa latina más allá de una
crisis sanitaria christophe bienvenido a
este escala en parís muchas gracias
cristo aventura sin duda alguna la
crisis de coronavirus que de sants que
se desarrolla en todo el mundo tiene
muchas cosas que son similares al
conjunto del mundo pero cuáles son las
especificidades que hacen que hoy en día
américa latina' precisamente se haya
convertido en ese epicentro de esta
crisis sanitaria mundial
hay varios parámetros que
lamentablemente fueron bien sabido por
mucha gente el primero del punto de
vista de la salud es que américa latina
se enfrenta a otra epidemia que es la
epidemia de dengue la más fuerte de toda
su historia en el año 2019 y este año
casi dos millones de personas impactadas
afectadas por la epidemia de dengue
después otra otro tema es el tema del
sistema de salud latinoamericano que es
un sistema que no es en capacidad de
a si puedo decir un choque un
golpe tan tanto grande como el de la
pandemia del cubil por razones
estructurales que tiene que ver con el
sistema de financiamiento la fractura
entre el sistema público sub equipado su
financiado y el sistema privado
muy importante que desarrollan
desigualdades y tercero punto yo creo
también es la desarticulación la
incapacidad de los gobiernos
latinoamericanos a gestionar a manejar
este golpe de manera mínimamente
coordinada no es que esos son temas en
lo sanitario en lo social y en lo
político a este propósito detengamos en
lo que usted menciona a propósito de la
precariedad del sistema sanitario de
américa latina hay un dato que usted
destaca en el informe son las
recomendaciones de la organización
mundial de la salud que dicen que los
países deben invertir 6% como mínimo del
producto interno bruto en el sistema de
salud y américa latina se encuentra en
un promedio del 2 por ciento en promedio
hay países que invierten mucho menos
esto ha sido determinante dijéramos para
ver qué países como colombia como méxico
como perú registran más de 600.000 casos
cada uno sí es absolutamente clave para
entender una cosa muy importante qué
tiene tiene un impacto en latinoamérica
como en el resto del mundo es que este
virus solamente demuestra indica las
vulnerabilidades de los de las
organizaciones sociales y se crece con
la falta o la debilidad de los sistemas
sociales
eso es el tema innato américa estamos en
eso porque obviamente el problema del
sistema sanitario latinoamericano es el
hecho de que se puede curar pero sí se
puede apagarlo porque si no no se puede
no el sistema público está muy débil
sobre todo después esos últimos años
donde la austeridad de los gobiernos fue
muy fuerte en particular en el sistema
sanitario que está pagando el precio de
la falta de inversión y de la falta de
consideración de los gobiernos como
sistema principal para
sociedad es el sistema privado en el
cual la gente tiene que pagar su cura no
puede asumir un golpe como el de la
pandemia esto es en términos del aspecto
sanitario de la crisis que se ha vuelto
una verdadera hecatombe ahora bien hay
la parte también económica que esta
aventura en concreto las previsiones que
dan los organismos internacionales es
que el producto interno bruto promedio
de la región deberá retroceder entre el
9 y el 10 por ciento se podrá decir es
más o menos lo que va a retroceder el
producto interno bruto en francia o en
otros países europeos pero sin tener la
base social de apoyo que permite
relanzar la economía en este sentido ese
retroceso que se puede considerar
histórico en muchos países cifras que
nunca antes se habían visto de caída de
la producción de la actividad económica
tendrán necesariamente consecuencias en
términos de empleo de aumento de la
desigualdad de la pobreza si enteramente
es un tema de gran preocupación porque
como dice usted lo que se va a ocurrir
en latinoamérica es sin presidente
después de una década ya que podemos
llamar a la negra en lo económico porque
antes
que vino la pandemia ya la situación de
la región fue muy mala con una
delegación más importante
en los últimos años que la de los años
antes de la llegada de la pandemia
entonces damos una recepción histórica
como lo dice la cepal la comisión de las
naciones unidas para las américas
entonces así consecuencias las conocemos
se van a distribuirse casi el 90% de las
pequeñas empresas en latinoamérica que
has que asumen 60 por ciento del empleo
en el país incluso del empleo informal
micro y mediana empresa salís y se va a
conocer un desempleo una desocupación
muy alta con casi 14 por ciento de la
población
oficialmente se va a conocer un aumento
muy fuerte de la pobreza con más de 230
millones de personas casi 40% de la
población latinoamericana después
una entrada en el siglo 21 que fue un
momento de avance muy fuerte en la lucha
en contra de esa progresa ahora está así
y también otro tema para latinoamérica
estará los problemas de hambre también
porque se habla de una inseguridad
alimentaria que podría tocar afectar a
casi 40 40 millones de personas en el
subcontinente eso se llama un cataclismo
exactamente el cataclismo variables pues
que hacen que la situación sea más que
preocupante más que tensa usted dice en
su informe una cuestión que llama mi
atención afirma que los gobiernos podrán
o no mantenerse en el poder
dependiendo de la respuesta que puedan
ofrecer a esta pandemia el problema es
que cuando uno analiza la situación la
mayoría de esos gobiernos salen
reprobados
el presidente bolsonaro en brasil-
negacionista completo aunque ahora
empieza a dar apoyo a los ciudadanos en
el caso de méxico el presidente
lópez obrador que es a cada medallitas
de la vírgen diciendo a mí me protege de
la salud la virgen una cosa
completamente increíble en chile el
sistema que queda al desnudo cuando
quiera el liberalismo total y podríamos
multiplicar hasta en este tipo de casos
entonces que lo que se puede esperar que
lo que se viene como escenario frente
esta situación sí absolutamente y una
vez más todo eso
ocurre después de un periodo de fuerte
de fuertes convulsiones sociales en
latinoamérica tenemos que recordarse que
hace apenas ocho meses varios países
estaban enfrentándose a muy
movilizaciones sociales en contra de la
vida cara en contra de la desigualdad y
de la corrupción y todas las razones
todos los temas por los cuales las
calles fueron salvajes de la casilla en
la calle están acabándose con la
pandemia del cob y de eso es el tema
entonces todos esos gobiernos o cual sea
su posición política de derecha y
centroderecha extrema derecha o
izquierda se van a conocer la misma cosa
porque hay un viento de desconfianza
política tan fuerte en américa latina en
contra de los gobiernos de las
instituciones en general y por otra
parte está esa caída este fracaso social
en todos los países que para los
gobiernos se va a hacer
o una amenaza muy fuerte sobre su
sobrevivencia y eso vamos a verlo con
varios escenarios y configuraciones
nacionales en los próximos meses en
latinoamérica a este propósito que esta
aventura efectivamente se vienen varias
citas electorales en medio de una
pandemia de una crisis histórica no este
año por ejemplo normalmente habrá el
referéndum en octubre en chile habrá
elecciones en bolivia entre otros el año
entrante hay elecciones presidenciales
en perú hay elecciones legislativas en
mexico hay elecciones en chile en fin
qué es lo que se puede ver hay más habrá
más inestabilidad dado esta situación de
los movimientos sociales que están ahora
en un impacto por causa de esta crisis
por parte del problema de esos
movimientos son su salida política cómo
traducir entre comillas un movimiento
social en respuesta política
institucional eso es el tema recurrente
el desafío permanente de los movimientos
por otro parte los gobiernos son
gobiernos que no tienen muchas muchas
imagen de mayorías para para manejar la
situación que viene porque son gobiernos
que no tiene recursos que son
dependientes de los mercados financieros
y los mercados económicos globales
porque la economía latinoamérica sobre
todo sur americana depende mucho de la
demanda internacional en recursos
naturales en materias primas primeras en
lo que se van a comprar los chinos los
norteamericanos los europeos que se van
también a conocer crisis económica es
muy fuerte
también el tema de la volatilidad de los
precios de las commodities en fin una
serie de parámetros estructurales que
son afuera de la soberanía de los
gobiernos latinoamericanos que se van a
depender de tendencias y de situaciones
que son decisiones que son afuera de
américa latina en las organizaciones
financieras internacionales
mundial de la contracción del comercio
mundial etcétera etcétera así que no lo
veo muy bien lamentablemente para todos
esos gobiernos y la inestabilidad puede
ser también una situación de confusiones
de autoritarismo político también para
manejar entre comillas las demandas
sociales que no podrán encontrar
una respuesta no concreta por parte de
ellos entonces yo creo que estamos en un
ciclo donde el autoritarismo político
también el aumento el crecimiento de la
represión social por parte de las
fuerzas armadas de las policías y el
error de las fuerzas armadas se van a
hacer más importante en los últimos
meses pues sin duda alguna este es un
panorama bastante preocupante estamos
llegando ya al final de esta escala en
parís no me queda sino agradecer a
christoph de lectura director de
investigaciones del instituto de
relaciones internacionales y
estratégicas en francia su presencia en
estos estudios yo recuerdo que usted es
autor del informe kobe 19 en américa
latina más allá de una crisis sanitaria
muchas gracias por su presencia le
agradezco mucho por la invitación y a
ustedes les damos otra cita aquí la
próxima semana en otra escala en parís
[Música]